in this video we'll see an alternative
for visualizing undirected graphical
models like the conditional random field
known as the factor graph we've seen in
the previous video that one way of
visualizing in conditional random field
is to draw a network where each node
would correspond to one of the random
variables in the model and then we will
draw an edge between each node that
share at least one factor in the product
of factors form of the conditional
random field now one problem with this
visualization is that it's actually
ambiguous so we notice for instance that
we actually have a clip between and
there's a mistake here this would be x2
we actually have a click between y1 y2
and x2 another click like this here that
is a subset of the graph where each node
each pair of node is connected to each
other and this actually kind of suggests
that perhaps that was a factor that had
as it's three arguments y1 y2 and x2
because in this case that I have to draw
an edge between y1 y2 an edge between y1
and x2 and another edge between y2 and
x2 but in fact in my actual model all I
had was three factors one between y1 and
y2 another one between y2 and x2 and
another one between y1 and x2 and you
know in some sense it's as if I had just
a single factor which was the product so
a single factor between y1 y2 and x2
where I which was the product of my
simpler factor y1 and y2 times the
factor between y2 and x2 times the
factor between y1 and x2 but what if I
had a model with actually had a factor
between these three random variables
that was more complicated it's actually
they would they sort of correspond to
different models one which is a bit more
complicated can
more sophisticated interactions between
these three random variables and the
other one which just assumes that you
know the way I'm going to model
preferences between the values of these
three random variables is as a product
of preferences between pairs of
variables and so what we'll see is that
there's another type of graphical
visualization which is going to allow us
to distinguish between these two cases
so this visualization is known as a
factor graph and the idea is that we're
actually going to add nodes in our graph
that corresponds to the factors so in
our conditional random field which is a
linear chain and as a context window of
radius 1 this will correspond to that
this factor craft
so usually factors we illustrate them as
a little square like this and now each
square corresponds to a factor in my
product of factors form of my
conditional random field and now each
factor node is going to be connected to
its argument to the random variables
that are correspond to arguments of the
factor so for instance we have this
factor here and it's connected to Y 3
and X 3 because in the factor which is
this it depends on X 3 and it depends on
Y 3 similarly I'm gonna have this factor
here and it's going to be connected to X
2 and Y through Y sorry X 2 and Y 3
because again it's a factor that depends
on X 2 in 1 3 and so on say for this
factor and also I have a pairwise factor
here which is here which is connected to
y3 and y4 because it expresses a
preference over the joint value of y3
and y4 now the reason why this is less
ambiguous is because now we explicitly
have the factors illustrated in our
visualization so consider this very
simple example where I have this Markov
network
corresponds to three variables each
connected to each other like we've
discussed before well in this case we
don't really know whether it's it's
actually a model where we have three
factors that are over pairs or just a
single factor over three variables
however given this factor graph well if
I was to draw to infer what is the mark
of network visualization based on that
factor graph well I'd have to draw an
edge between this node and this node
because there's this factor that
connects them so this there's one factor
that involves the two of them same thing
because at if this factor I need to draw
an edge in the Mac mark up network
varies between these two variables and
similarly for that factor I'd get an
edge here and we see that also this
factor graph with a single factor will
actually correspond to the same mark up
network so while going from factor graph
to mark up network is well defined
inferring from a mark of network what is
the factor graph is actually ambiguous
so that's not a well-defined operation
so we've lost less information by
drawing so or we're providing more
information by drawing the factor graph
as opposed to drawing the mark of
network there's still some advantage in
the mark of network it's kind of more
intuitive and easier to infer the
conditional independencies like we've
done before though we could extend that
logic to factor factor graphs but in all
cases when the information about the
factors is not as much important and
we're more concerned about showing the
Independence's or dependencies between
the variable often we'll favor
drawing a mark of network but if the
actual information about the factors is
important then we'll want to use a
factor graph all right so this covers
the the second type of visualization for
undirected graphical model known as the
factor graph